patrick corbin 20 starts at nat's park
as a nat 9-3 with a 2-5-7 era in this
ballpark so he likes to pitch here one
out and it brings up marcel ozuna two
balls into strike for corbin
and that one is shot up the middle of
base hit here comes acuna streaking
around third running free and easy the
throw to the plate is too high and late
put the braves in front one nothing
another hit for ozuna in this series in
the brave strike first
six for seven now in the series with a
walk corbin sets here's the pitch to
riley half swing did he go they'll
appeal and yes on a slider in the dirt
kicked off the shin guards of goals but
riley is already headed toward the
braves dugout so he's out of the inning
is over on the first strikeout for
patrick corbin a run on three hits a
stolen base for the braves and two men
left and what do you look for from ian
tonight as he tries to rebound from a
rough one last time out yeah first two
starts six innings threw great only that
one hit versus the yankees last start
three innings threw that ball wide to
first and it kind of sent him on a
little bit of a tail spin i just want to
see him come back out and throw tonight
and he chased a high fastball good pitch
from anderson he's got strikeout stuff
more than one strikeout per inning and
his knights off to a good start
anderson's first pitch fastball is
popped up
jammed in
shallow right field out there and
waiting for it as ozzie albee's easy
one-handed catch
and a scoreless first inning for ian
anderson no runs no hits one walk one
left at the end of one complete in
washington it's the braves one and the
national is nothing
away here at the top of inning number
two
here's a payoff pitch
and it's in there cold strike three that
slider bending in from the outside and
corbin has his second strikeout he'd
like to end the inning here and freeman
next inning the pitch
and check swing the appeal
it's a swinging strike three on a slider
corbin gets his third strike out at a
big one the braves failed to score in
the top of the second luis garcia bats
runners first and second nobody out
garcia offers last seven inning at 275
in 23 games fastball has popped up to
shallow center field coming in for it is
ronald acuna plenty of time to get there
gliding one-handed catch for the first
out aims back to second gomes back to
first let's see if the runners move on a
3-2 they don't and taylor hits it high
in the air to center again right in the
center of that dc heart
easy play of cuny nice comeback after
two walks two pop outs to center and
henderson's one out away from preserving
the lead anderson nods yes and pitches
swinging a missy struck him out with an
excellent change up again so anderson
walks the first two batters of the
second and then retires garcia taylor
and hernandez one two three let's see
freddie struggle against an awful lot of
left-handed pitchers but this is one guy
for whatever reason that has been
kryptonite for the braves first baseman
freddy's now five for 30 in his career
against corbin swaying gonna miss on a
3-2 slider
that had freddie freeman pulling off
that's the 13th time in 31 official bats
patrick urban struck out freddie pitch
swinging a slow topper to third it's
handled by cabrera he'll throw to second
garcia has it for the force out on
darnold the braves with no runs on one
hit and one man left and we go to the
bottom half of the third it's the braves
one and the nationals nothing so
anderson has been i guess you would say
effectively wild or just wild 44 pitches
only 20 strikes but he hasn't given up a
run or a hit
line drive and freddie freeman handles a
one hopper at anderson to the bag good
play by freddie and good job by ian
getting over to first base
hit in the air to center field and deep
turning one way than the other as acuna
turns around on the warning track when
he'll hop in the air he reels it in
turner with loud contact to the center
of the diamond and acuna turned it
the batter with duval at second ozzie is
batting night
hard hit ball to right field a base hit
duval chugging around third he's going
to score and ozzy albee's comes up with
a big two-out hit and atlanta extends
the lead
ninth rbi for ozzie there goes the
runner the 3-2 pitch
strike three called fastball inside
corner locks up pecunia and corbin ends
the inning with strikeout number six
that'll bring in eric thames
3-2 strike three outside corner
perfectly placed anderson has his third
strikeout
strike three a change-up and garcia rung
up four strikeouts for ian anderson two
of them in the fourth inning ian
anderson rolling merrily along for
atlanta he's got the eight nine and one
hitters coming up for washington so his
69th delivery is a change-up swing and a
miss three of the last four outs for
anderson have been on strikeouts two of
them looking one of them swinging
strike three a big hook back to back
strikeouts actually it's three in a row
for anderson two outs and back to the
top of the order
next pitch to holt this one is fair roll
to freddy a little easier play he'll
step on the back and anderson is rolling
folks after a shaky second he has given
up one total hit he leads two nothing
after five base is empty for anderson 88
pitches juan soto ready here comes and
he threw it right by him another change
up boy that has been
such a fun pitch to watch
the nationals right now are befuddled by
it
on the ground into the shift dansby's
got it from the cut of the grass three
up three down again anderson has thrown
90 pitches he leads two nothing with a
one hit shut up for anderson's back to
work with thames gomes and garcia great
game plan great execution at this point
and he got a swing in the miss with the
change up three pitches to po disposes
of eric thames for the second time eight
strikeouts
and he just got gomes to swing into miss
at a breaking ball a new career high in
strikeouts that's number nine he's at 99
with this one and it's whacked into
right field and it's caught and ian
anderson became the first brave to
complete seven innings this year so
after eaton singles in steal second he's
there with two out and trey turn of the
batter
and turner hits it well
deep right center approaching the
scoreboard it'll one hop the nets are on
the board eaton scores two
one game and it's up to robles to decide
the fate of this game bases loaded two
outs fly ball hit toward right that's a
can of corn duval is there and the
braves hang on and win it
ian anderson is three and oh with seven
innings of one hit shutout ball